[Music]
I'm in a pretty good mood considering I
saw someone eating alone today I don't
know can I wonder can anyone relate I
just get sad when I see somebody eating
alone so like I need this full fuel it
breaks my heart eating soup they were
eating soup blowing on it it's too hot
and the happier the food I feel it's
sadder is watching someone needed a loan
like cake you ever see someone eating
cake by themselves Museum food court
it's like you did something cultured
bill you own two treats now don't get me
wrong I actually love eating alone I
love eating alone just not in public
like I had dinner on my couch last night
like I do you know why the couch is the
one place I'm free to eat how I like to
eat like a toddler Chinese takeout
dropping stuff no pants in sight using
my belly as a table and it's dangerous
too cuz I have a white couch I should
say I had a white couch I toddler eat on
that thing so much now it's more
camouflage but I don't care toddler Pete
doesn't care about stains I'm proud of
him each staying on my couch it's like a
memory I show him off like a bad boy
shows off his scars yeah
McDonald's ketchup oh eight pad thai
summer of thirteen still wet
the key to toddler eating it's all about
eating with your hands I love eating
with my hands I love it
I'm not ashamed but the man says you got
to use a fork why when I got God's Forks
and I'm not just yeah sure kind of a
late-blooming that one let's slap
together our God Forks and show support
and I'm not just God for canned fruit or
pizza or chicken wings you know socially
approved hand foods
I'm forking hummus pasta even your heart
your soups if you let them cool down a
bit no no it's like the arcade claw game
but the prize is always lukewarm
minestrone toddler style I've got a
couple methods for fried rice that's
right
sometimes I snowplow it right into my
mouth in the garden like I'm a cop on a
stakeout if the charge is being
delicious this rice is guilty or I'll
let the fried rice harden in my fridge
overnight I can do a solid landmass it's
like a new kind of food hard rice and I
tear off chunks like a giant getting a
handful of Earth bringing it up to my
face single grains falling off like
erosion
what if I'm out in dignified society and
I gotta use silverware give me the spoon
love the spoon fork too aggressive for
metallic spikes to jam into your food
why it's already dead
Kevin and that act out I was having a
meal with a man named Kevin there's some
pressure with the fork - you got to hold
it right like on a date got to hold it
properly like a single chopstick you
know I mean he can't be on a date like
this hold on like that that's a
deal-breaker
what do you work on a chain gang someone
announced the arrival of this meal with
a whistle it's a good job today
rocks breaking real easy - and that's
not enough with the fork if you go to
the fancy place you got to pick the
right fork salad fork dinner fork shrimp
fork same fork who's the making
up new forks heir to the fork fortune I
say give me the spoon love the spoon
it's welcoming you can put them on your
nose got a laugh they're like the fun
uncle of silverware all cold and smooth
you know like your fun uncle a spoon
feels like when your dentist put set up
mirror in your mouth I love that he's
been picking he's been picking then he
takes the break with that smooth mirror
that's what a spoon feels like to me I
love it
huh a break I love it in fact before I
die I'd love to eat like ice cream with
a dentist mirror
when there be great those of you that
are laughing or picturing it you know
what I mean that's that's a great moment
then you go to the dentist he's like
you've been eating a lot of sweets you
like you in a way I think you'd
appreciate
[Music]